foreign
Daniel is with us in Mobile Alabama hi
Daniel how are you hey I'm great it's uh
honor to be on with you well thank you
sir how can we help I've got a I've got
two questions my first question is
the way the market is today
I've lost roughly sixty thousand
you know yeah I've got a Vanguard Target
retirement account
my question is to stop the bleeding
so you got like a half million dollars
in it
no I had about 225
000 in it
and you lost 60 000 since when
uh
that's about a year in the past year
well the Market's down 13 that wouldn't
be 60 000 on 220.
well I'm down about 160.
wow
oh you're down about 60 you said go down
to 160 I see okay yeah yeah okay all
right um and my question I've been
listening to a lot of things on the
radio and I've talked to a few people
what is your opinion about indexed
annuities
would I be would there be any advantage
to go into something like that just to
stop the bleeding yeah it's too late
I mean you're not stopping the bleeding
unless you think it's going to continue
to bleed out and I don't
um and so the only person that gets hurt
on a roller coaster is one jumps off in
the middle of the ride
and so
um you know uh I'm I'm not sure that I'm
a fan of uh your initial selection of
funds
um but how old are you
six to six okay I'm 62 and I have mine
across four types growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and in the last 12 months
the stock market and the Dow Jones has
lost about 13 percent and that's about
what I'm down is about 13 you're down
more than 13 percent
is what you're telling me so
um I would not move it to indexed
annuities I don't have a diamond indexed
annuities
um and uh
so do you need the money today no okay
um you've got other money yes okay
what's it in
um well
I'm retired
um
so I've got my teacher retirement I've
gotten a social social security
um I'm debt free
except if I say a debt
um helping pay for law school for one of
my my daughter okay
so that's really the only thing that I
have that's your only nest egg
uh yes and you're living off of your
teacher pension and stuff okay yeah okay
now I've got
I had about 75 000 just in savings that
I'd been putting some take diverting
some to there to be ready for the Law
School tuition good okay that's fine
yeah that's where it should be that's
good all right um well the the Target
Fund that you have or the target funds
that you have what's the track record on
them long term how old are they
I can't answer that okay I got in about
20.
about 2014.
okay so you've been you've been in eight
years and it's not been a problem it's
just this particular downturn you really
took it on the chin yeah you've written
out a couple other downturns so yes like
spring of 2020 remember that it dropped
like crazy
remember that I I'll be honest with you
for the most most of the time I don't
even look at it okay all right well if
you go back and look
your your fund most funds dropped
substantially around the coveted
quarantine hit
and then they came back in September
or back to where they were they're back
even but a lot of people jumped out with
that down downturn because they're
freaking out over everything over covid
right
um and so right now we got a Biden freak
out going on or whatever you want to
call it inflation freak out
um
and uh corporate profits are down and so
stocks are down
and um because inflation's putting the
squeeze on the profit margins as well as
uh causing prices to go up so um
ah Daniel no index funds I would not do
to answer your question what I would do
is sit down with a smartvester pro and
um let's do a little bit of learning
because I'm not sure I can answer your
question without I want to go back on
this Target Fund and say I've got to get
comfortable with the history of it that
its recovery rate is about as good as
the Market's recovery rate if I get
comfortable with that I'm probably just
going to leave it alone
if I'm uncomfortable that this is a good
selection and I need to move it into
some other funds I'm going to move it
from one set of funds that are down to
another set of funds that are down that
have a better recovery rate when the
market turns up
I got you that's what I would do but no
the index fund is mythology because it
has to ride the other stuff too it's
indexed off the stock market that's what
it's indexed off of and they put some
checks and balances in there in charge
of double commissions uh to where you
think you've got your principal
protected and other stuff it's an
insurance product and so I I wouldn't
screw with it I don't put any money in
that kind of stuff I just ride these
waves and the good news is you don't
have to have the money and you can
afford to ride the wave what you need is
and what I would need if I were you and
I'm asking you to get this is some
intellectual
um
comfort
that the recovery rate on this fund when
the stock market recovers is reasonable
that it's going to come back as the
market comes back meaning that the fund
is riding the market wave not just a bad
fund
um and it's scaring me because it's down
further than the market pretty
substantially so that's why I want you
to look at that if you told me you were
off 13 I'd say I just tell you sit tight
write it because that's what the
Market's off
but when you're down more than 13
percent in in 12 months then if you're
down from 220 to 160 in that period of
time then there's something else going
on here and I want to look at that this
this may be a more volatile fund which
might mean it might recover faster
actually so you just need to learn the
fun so jump on ramseysolutions.com click
on Smart investor Pro and learn because
Christina the trick with this is history
is the only shot you've got at getting
some comfort
on these things I mean if you look at a
phone that's got an 80-year history like
I've owned one that's 80 years old okay
and I can go back and go it's got 11.2
percent rate of return for 80 freaking
years and it's down 13 I can kind of be
calm you know history gives me Comfort
right
um but but if if I don't know those
things then it's harder to be calm yeah
and I think this is such an important
conversation right now to have because I
think a lot of gen Z Millennials who
this is their first time writing out you
know a bear Market a rough Market it's
just important like you said The only
person who gets hurt on a roller coaster
is the person who jumped off you know
it's just important to be able to look
historically you know what are these
markets like and then just look at the
funds and see the history see the track
record and then have peace As you move
forward and not freak out and jump off
the great news is that Daniel can live
on his pension and he can just leave
this alone and it can afford to let it
ride back up that's the great news in
this call